voir ce que tu as dit précisément sur
emmanuel bach ont notamment c'est une
déclaration qui a fait pour le
documentaire très controversé hold up
réalisé par pierre barnérias mais
d'après ce que tu lis près les
résidentes aurait affirmé au téléphone
qu il soignerait se soignerait à la
chloroquine s'ils étaient touchés par le
courant d'un virus exact c'est à dire
c'est ce qui s'est passé devant témoin
je suis un haut-parleur chez avec le ch
avec le président donc je dis ah je suis
un coup d'oeil à mes amis et je leur dis
voilà je vais c'est incroyable à ce que
tu dit jean-marie parce que on est en
direct un sur ses vitres
c'est fou parce que ça ne prouve rien
rien n'est sûr mais comme je dis
diablement quelle est cette conversation
qui était privée je les balancer ça
alors on passe à dahra partie parce que
moi j'ai une question à se poser est où
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
vous aussi c'est parti jean marie est ce
que est ce que tu penses que c'est
cc c'est cool de près 2 voilà de faire
référence à des conversations privées
ce que tu penses que le prix assez cool
coach je te dis que tu on marche sur mon
tube un oxygène
pourquoi tu es juste avant de mourir je
je je parle c'est en fait quoi parce que
toi tu étais très proches - le président
n'ont jamais été très proche et a eu un
moment il m'a appelé pour dire
j'aimerais parler avec vous j'ai su et
me l'a dit lui même qui regardait toutes
mes vidéos je vous écoute je vous écoute
toujours d'ailleurs et j'ai envie de
parler avec vous moi plutôt flatteur
c'était comme un fou oui oui c'est à
dire c'est quand même le sait quand même
de président de peinture donc c'est lui
qui sait déjà c'est un mec élégant et
c'est c'est un serpent ces cas dans le
livre de la jungle et confiance
prions que
witt récemment un peu stupéfaits d'abord
d'avoir le président au téléphone rigide
qui n'a plus la convivialité et dont
j'ai tout simplement dit que maudire est
un pote comme je t'appelle ma poule
j'ai envie de lui dire je le tutoyer je
le voyais une phrase sur deux j'ai dit
franchement président un coup d'oeil
mes potes si tu as le site elle
coronavirus qui ait su fait tu fais le
traitement du professeur out et il m'a
dit oui oui mais c'était quand cet appel
je repars donc dans cet appel c'est bah
c'était avant ses aventures donc il est
dans le round ça la mode quand il était
à marseille pour voir le professeur a ou
bien devrions encore y en avait avant
les vides sud en fait oui c'est à dire
avant mais bon tu josy t-il on s'en fout
mais je sais pas s'il a fait le
traitement ou pas ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de députés qui se
soigne à l'hydraulique l'euro qui s'est
déjà suffisant pour être insupportable
comment est-ce qu'on peut interdire
alors médicaments qu'elle avait un
médicament qui a fait ses preuves et
comment on peut cela dit l administrer à
soi même
comment alors est-ce que c'est pas dit
qu'il l'a pris parce qu'il a dit qu'il
aurait à l'époque je crois qu'il n'a pas
été soignée l'hydro de cyclones ont
marre quand il a eu le jus personne
personne n'a dit ça j'ai dit simplement
ce qui m'a dit se trouve qu'il est allé
le voir pratiquement sans prévenir
personne il est allé voir le professeur
raoul et dans le monde entier le
professeur raoul tu es une star absolue
et il ya énormément de spécialistes qui
disent oui si on avait moi il m'a parlé
d'un truc le président aussi il m'a dit
oui mais jean-marie il ya la balance
bénéfice-risque toi est-ce que si on
avait utilisé l'hydraulique l'origine
dès les premiers jours en traitement est
ce qu'on aurait fait 80 mille morts
n'ont jamais de la vie
les russes igor keane on l'apprend
dix ans et deux milliards de personnes
l'ont prise donc toi